mes chers amis nous sommes la droite
nous sommes les héritiers du général de
Gaulle vous êtes ces militants courageux
toujours vaillants comme moi vous voulez
plus d'autorité car le respect manque
dans notre société nos lois sont
bafouées nos frontières violées nos
policiers gendarmes pompiers enseignants
élus sont attaqués nos traditions sont
malmenées nos modes de vie sont remises
en cause je veux rétablir l'ordre
partout et pour tous je veux vous donner
la liberté d'agir ceux qui travaillent
doivent gagner plus que ceux qui vivent
de l'assistana ceux qui ont travaillé
durent toute leur vie doivent être
protégés nous devons être le parti de la
baisse des impôts de la diminution des
normes de l'effacement de la
bureaucratie mes amis que la France est
belle sublime éternelle résistant
résiliente nous devons protéger ses
racines sa culture sont patrimoine nous
ne pouvons pas la laisser aux mains des
idéologues woquistes des islamistes de
ceux qui l'habillent à coup de béton
d'éolienne demain avec vous avec la
droite au cœur je veux me battre pour
cette France que nous aimons
passionnément et que nous voulons voir
grandes belles et respectées
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis
mes chers amis c'est un honneur un
bonheur que de pouvoir m'exprimer devant
vous membres du Conseil national
militant
militant des républicains et d'abord
militant de la France si nous sommes ici
si nous avons adhéré à cette grande
famille politique qui depuis plus de 50
ans a construit la France d'aujourd'hui
une France forte qui était respectée qui
était fier c'est parce que nous avons
cette France au cœur que nous aimons la
France et si nous sommes ici notre seul
objectif et une bien entendu de
redresser la France je veux
naturellement dira à mes amis qui sont
ici engagés dans cette compétition une
compétition qui se doit et elle est
d'être sereine d'être amicale d'être
presque fraternel
merci
la fois Aurélien à Bruno pour leur
engagement pour leur conviction pour
leur talent des excuses à Bruno parce
que
quelqu'un qui était grimpé sur un pilone
m'a bloqué
pendant une heure et demie dans un TGV
puisque j'arrivais de Lyon où j'étais
hier soir en meeting avec Laurent
Wauquiez et bien oui merci à vous de
faire vivre cette belle compétition et à
l'initiative d'Annick je salue pour son
travail pour son courage tout en saluant
à ses côtés le président du Sénat mon
ami Gérard Larcher merci à vous toutes
et à vous tous d'être fidèle à notre
famille dans des moments difficiles
Aurélien moi je ne souhaite que personne
porte le cercueil des républicaines
demain jeunes ou moins jeune moi je
souhaite que demain notre famille se
redresse tout simplement pour redresser
la France nous pensons et nous
partageons pour l'essentiel et c'est
heureux les mêmes valeurs les mêmes
convictions les mêmes racines
mais ceux qui importent aujourd'hui pour
celui qui demande devra diriger notre
famille politique
c'est de faire en sorte que cette
famille politique ne disparaisse pas
la question que tous vous vous posez
et quand nous voyons ces salles qui se
restreignent on ne peut pas éloigner
cette question
avons-nous encore un avenir cette
famille celle du général de Gaulle celle
de Georges Pompidou de Jacques Chirac de
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing de Nicolas
Sarkozy a-t-elle encore un avenir c'est
à cette réponse c'est à cette question
que nous devons apporter une réponse
déterminée claire méthodique mes amis
moi ce que je veux vous proposer c'est
une méthode c'est une méthode pour que
nous retrouvions le chemin de la
victoire cette méthode elle passe par
des étapes claires définies balisé je
veux tracer une route droite dans tous
les sens du terme vers un seul objectif
la victoire à l'élection présidentielle
de 2027
[Applaudissements]
dans la Cinquième République
cette cinquième République qui a été
bâtie par le général de Gaulle il y a
qu'une élection qui détermine toutes les
autres il y en a une qui dépasse toutes
les autres parce qu'elle porte l'avenir
de la France c'est l'élection
présidentielle nous pouvons gagner
toutes les élections si nous ne gagnions
pas l'élection présidentielle pour la
troisième fois consécutive et bien nous
disparaîtrons toutes nos forces toutes
nos convictions toute notre énergie doit
être mobilisée vers ce cap qui nous
attend et qui nous regardent nous avons
et nous connaissons le but le terme de
ce chemin que je veux ouvrir avec vous
dans l'unité et dans le rassemblement
il y a des étapes sur cette route il y a
des garde-fous que nous devons apposer
de chaque côté il y a des balises que
nous devons suivre au moment le plus
obscur de la période qui nous entoure
alors oui mes amis c'est cette méthode
que je veux proposer nous avons
aujourd'hui besoin plus que jamais de
pragmatisme de bon sens de méthode cette
méthode que je veux vous proposer alors
que tout semble compromis doit nous
conduire à nourrir et à bâtir une grande
espérance
oui
Maréchal Foch disait ma droite est
enfoncée ma gauche à céder j'attaque
c'est cet état d'esprit qui doit nous
guider c'est cet espoir qui doit nous
animer nous ne pouvons nous résigner
nous ne pouvons démissionner nous ne
pouvons nous soumettre nous ne pouvons
nous coucher nous ne pouvons négocier
avec telle ou tel nous devons être
debout fort indépendant libre guidé par
notre passé nous ne venons pas de nulle
part nous sommes les héritiers de cette
immense famille politique
j'ai grandi certaines diront pas
beaucoup dans une famille gaullistes
profondément gaulliste guidé par un
grand-père qui était prisonnier de
guerre qui vouée une venir étable
vénération générale de Gaulle libérateur
de la France nous avons vécu avec
enthousiasme les plus belles et les plus
grandes pages de cette cinquième
République le redressement de la
situation économique le redressement de
nos institutions après les affres de la
politique politicienne de la Quatrième
République dans laquelle monsieur Macron
est en train de nous faire revenir ce
petit feu qui cuit sur les petits
réchauds dans les arrières cuisine et
bien nous avons vécu les plus grandes
pages aussi du progrès industriel du
progrès scientifique du progrès sociétal
avec Simone Veil que nous ne devons pas
laisser à la gauche ou à droite
c'est tout cela c'est tout cela la
droite
notre droite c'est une droite qui aime
la France qui est fier de son histoire
qui la revendique qui veut défendre ce
qu'elle est sa culture son identité 6 15
singulières six spécifiques la droite
c'est dire que nous sommes tout à la
fois les héritiers d'une civilisation
judéo-chrétienne qui a éclairé le monde
qui a apporté les libertés comme nous
sommes tout à la fois les héritiers du
millénaire capétien les héritiers des
soldats de l'angueux comme les héritiers
des grognards de l'empire des poilus de
Verdun des maquisards du plateau des
Glières des pêcheurs de l'île de Saint
tout à la fois
héritier de Saint-Louis de Louis XIV de
Bonaparte de Clémenceau de De Gaulle
c'est cette France dont nous avons été
les acteurs dans les dernières années
que nous devons rebâtir reconstruire à
laquelle nous devons redonner une force
une espérance une fierté un honneur
alors oui c'est fort de cette histoire
c'est fort de cet héritage c'est fort de
ses racines que nous devons préparer
l'avenir le préparer pour la Genèse le
préparer pour les Français qui
aujourd'hui sont dans la difficulté qui
souffrent le préparer pour relever les
défis auxquels sont confrontés un pays
aujourd'hui soumis sur la pente du
déclin du déclassement de la dégradation
oui nous devons redresser la France nous
en avons le devoir et la responsabilité
parce que nous ne venons pas de nulle
part parce que nous sommes les héritiers
de cette grande famille politique et que
je ne veux pas demain qu'on écrive le
mot fin à la dernière page du livre du
parti et de la famille gaulliste c'est
tout cela qui doit nous guider alors
d'abord mes amis sur cette route il y a
des étapes essentielles
oui nous devons reconstruire un grand
parti des idées oui nous devons
retravailler nos propositions oui nous
redevons redonner un cap sur des valeurs
fortes des valeurs je le dis de droite
je suis de droite j'ai la droite au
coeur j'ai la droite au cœur parce que
la droite elle doit parler à tous les
Français parce que pour moi être de
droite s'aimer notre histoire c'est
vouloir la protéger parce que pour moi
être de droite c'est croire en l'ordre
républicain c'est croire à l'autorité
qui fait de l'ordre le pilier central de
nos valeurs Peggy disait l'ordre et seul
l'ordre seul fait la liberté alors que
le désordre fait la servitude oui nous
aurons besoin de cette autorité qui
remet de l'ordre dans la société là où
règne le désordre dans la rue dans
compte partout nous aurons besoin aussi
de cette attachement à notre identité
française si malmené aujourd'hui et puis
nous aurons besoin de promouvoir un
grand projet de liberté économique qui
dessert tous les nœuds qui aujourd'hui
bloquent les initiatives tous ceux qui
empêchent les artisans les commerçants
les professions libérales les chefs
d'entreprise de libérer les énergies
nous aurons besoin de faire souffler sur
l'économie française un grand vent de
renouveau qui fera baisser les impôts et
les charges oui demain nous devons tout
à la fois être le parti de l'ordre et le
parti de la baisse des impôts nous avons
besoin de ces priorités nous avons
besoin dans ces grandes valeurs qui nous
réunissent qui nous rassemblent ces
trois piliers porteurs l'autorité
l'identité la liberté nous avons pas
besoin d'être identifié nous avons
besoin d'un programme lisible nous avons
besoin d'un programme différent de nos
adversaires ou de nos ennemis nous avons
besoin de symboles qui redonne la fierté
d'être républicain nous n'avons plus la
nécessité et nous devons couper le
robinet d'eau tiède nous devons rompre
avec les tabous du politiquement correct
nous devons libérer notre nos énergies
nos propositions nous devons avoir le
courage de balayer les tabous qui depuis
trop longtemps ont entravé le cours de
notre action de notre parole même c'est
tout cela que nous devons faire dans ce
grand projet de refondation de notre
famille politique oui nous avons besoin
d'idées claire oui nous avons besoin
d'idées fortes oui nous avons besoin de
dire qu'aujourd'hui nous devons protéger
de façon intangible l'uniforme de la
République et que tous ceux qui touchent
un uniforme de la République qu'il soit
celui d'un policier d'un gendarme d'un
pompier d'un militaire d'un magistrat
mais aussi qu'il touche à un enseignant
à un élu à un dépositaire de l'autorité
publique systématiquement et
automatiquement le soir même doit dormir
en prison oui oui nous avons oui nous
avons la nécessité de dire que ceux qui
ne respectent pas nos droits nos lois en
venant de l'étranger alors qu'on leur a
accordé un titre de séjour qui traduit
quelque part impact de confiance qui est
passé avec la République que cela ne
mérite plus de rester en France et que
lorsqu'il commettent un crime ou un
délit sur le territoire national où ils
ont été accueillis il faut leur dire
clairement qu'ils n'ont plus rien à y
faire et que la réponse pour eux c'est
la pris l'avion oui nous avons
l'exigence aujourd'hui de dire que nous
devons baisser les impôts que les
Français ne peuvent plus supporter
d'être assommé aujourd'hui de taxes de
charge de cotisation d'impôts nous
sommes le pays au monde avec le Danemark
qui paye le plus d'impôts nous avons un
taux de prélèvement obligatoire 7 points
supérieurs à celui de la moyenne des
pays de l'Union européenne et bien être
de droite c'est dire que demain si nous
retournons au pouvoir la première des
priorités sera de baisser les impôts et
les taxes des Français et que nous
devrons nous attaquer aux impôts les
plus injustes c'est pour cela que
l'année dernière au Congrès et en
saluant les amis qui ont participé à ce
congrès Michel Barnier était là la vie
Bertrand et là et bien nous avons cette
responsabilité c'était l'idée que
j'avais porté de supprimer cette impôt
sur la mort et les droits de succession
comme nous avons le devoir aussi comme
nous avons aussi le devoir de faire en
sorte que la progressivité écrasante de
l'impôt sur le revenu soit aujourd'hui
considérablement baissé comme nous avons
le devoir d'alléger le poids qui pèse
sur les entreprises 100 milliards
d'impôts de production de plus ce qui
opère notre compétitivité ce qui nourrit
les délocalisations ce qui nous a
conduit à perdre un million et demi
d'emplois industriels depuis
1981 et de façon accélérée depuis 10 ans
oui nous devons être le parti de la
baisse des impôts pour les ménages ce
sera le meilleur moyen de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat à nos concit moyen
contrairement à la méthode de ceux qui
nous gouvernent aujourd'hui qui est
celle du chèque sans provision d'un
chèque sans provision qui a nourri et
qui a construit une dette abyssale de
3000 milliards d'euros c'est à dire
45000 € pour chacune et chacun d'entre
vous une dette aujourd'hui qui menace
notre indépendance notre souveraineté
aujourd'hui il faut avoir le courage de
dire que notre pays vit à crédit et
qu'il finance ses dépenses inconsidérées
grâce à la dette et grâce à l'impôt et
ça nous devons le changer nous devons
mettre un terme à ce paradoxe incroyable
insupportable d'un pays qui est celui
qui dépense le plus d'argent public
alors que nos services publics n'ont
jamais été aussi
inefficace nous devons mettre un terme à
cet autre paradoxe qui fait que les
coûts salariaux que supportent les
française sont parmi les plus élevés
d'Europe alors que les salaires des
Français sont parmi les plus faibles de
l'Union européenne oui nous devons être
demain le parti de la baisse des impôts
et le parti de la hausse des salaires
cela est possible cela doit être une
priorité ce n'est pas la conséquence de
politique que nous n'aurons pas le
courage de conduire cela doit être la
priorité d'une grande politique de
liberté économique qui allie la liberté
l'initiative l'esprit d'entreprendre à
l'intérieur de nos frontières et qui le
mari avec une souveraineté qui rompe
avec la naïveté qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on importe des produits qui ne sont
soumis à aucune norme que l'on impose à
nos entreprises à nos agriculteurs à nos
travailleurs en France cela n'est plus
possible voilà ce grand projet que nous
devons porter
identité c'est souhaité que la France
reste la France j'ai été le premier à
porter ce slogan même si d'autres l'ont
repris l'autorité c'est vouloir que la
loi de la République soit supérieure ou
à la loi des bandes et des plus forts la
liberté c'est dégager toutes ces
initiatives et libérées les Français
voilà un grand projet qui devra
également s'attaquer à tous les tabous
qui aujourd'hui et à tous les sujets
dont on a peut-être laissé de façon trop
facile le monopole a des gens
extraordinaires mon dangereux
l'environnement Bruno et Aurélien l'ont
dit ça ne peut pas être les délires de
Madame Rousseau la protection de la
planète oui c'est un sujet majeur oui
c'est un sujet qui préoccupe
légitimement la jeunesse mais c'est pour
cela que c'est à nous de zoomer c'est à
nous de dire nous avons été les Prom
peur de l'énergie nucléaire là où
Monsieur Hollande et Monsieur Macron
l'ont mis à mal nous avons été les
promoteurs du Grenelle de
l'environnement nous n'avons pas de
leçons à attendre de ceux qui
aujourd'hui prônent la fin du barbecue
l'interdiction de la consommation de
viande la fin du sapin de Noël à
Bordeaux la fin de tel ou tel attitude
irresponsabilité dangerosité de ces
nouveaux petits dictateurs en
talonnettes alors oui nous le disons
nous le disons très fortement la droite
ça doit être la confiance en la science
dans le progrès c'est comme ça que nous
y arriverons et puis nous devons parler
Aurélien l'a dit aussi tout à l'heure
des sujets qui touchent à au plus
profond et au plus grandes
préoccupations d'entre nous parler du
grand âge de la dépendance bien entendu
le plus grand scandale de la crise
sanitaire a été la façon dont nous avons
laissé traiter nos aînés 20 000 sont
morts dans les EHPAD sans qu'ils aient
eu accès au service de soins dans nos
hôpitaux sans qu'ils aient tu accès à la
réanimation et sans même que leur
famille ait pu assister à leur dernier
moment de vie et bien cette inhumanité
elle ne doit plus avoir place sur le
territoire de la République nous devons
construire aussi ce grand projet pour
nous aider et prendre en compte cette
évolution majeure et ce grand défi de la
société pour les années à venir il
faudra aussi renouer avec la jeunesse de
France on ne peut pas laisser nos
étudiants dans la misère économique on
ne peut pas aussi laisser nos étudiants
prisonniers dans des universités prises
à nos tâches par les idéologies
woquistes et par l'extrême gauche qui
aujourd'hui
menace tous ceux qui portent ces idées
oui ce projet
ce projet travaillé par une grande
fondation des idées que nous devons
porter dans notre famille politique doit
parler à tous les Français c'est une
évidence c'est la première pierre de et
la première balise de ce chemin un
projet de droite un projet courageux un
projet ouddacieux ensuite mes amis sur
cette route il faudra poser des
garde-fous et je le dis clairement là
aussi je crois qu'on est tous d'accord
d'ailleurs pour moi si demain j'ai
l'honneur de présider notre famille
politique jamais il n'y aura d'alliance
avec le pouvoir qui nous gouverne je le
dis très clairement
[Applaudissements]
on ne monte pas
on ne monte pas sur le Titanic qui coule
et je le dis à tous ceux qui nourrissent
ce sombre des saints nous devons plus
que jamais être indépendant parce que
oui nous avons cette responsabilité
cette histoire ce devoir que je
rappelais tout à l'heure parce que nous
avons une place singulière dans la vie
politique nous n'avons à nous soumettre
à personne ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
nous devons être droit nous devons être
libres nous devons être indépendants
c'est le seul moyen que notre famille
politique retrouve le chemin de la
victoire et de l'espérance l'un des
parents l'indépendance de toutes les
pressions de toutes les manipulations de
toutes les négociations mon parcours
vous le savez a toujours été guidé par
cette fidélité j'ai adhéré au RPR à 16
ans je n'ai jamais changé de famille
politique j'ai toujours combattu toute
forme pense avec ce pouvoir ou avec
d'autres je n'ai jamais voté monsieur
Macron je le dis ni au premier ni au
second tour des élections
présidentielles je combats je combats je
combats au quotidien dans ma ville de
Nice et dans la région Provence Côte
d'Azur ceux qui se sont compromis avec
le macronisme et qui sont nos
adversaires et auxquels on a fait mordre
la poussière aux dernières élections
législatives en gagnant 5
circonscriptions dans les
Alpes-Maritimes quand la droite est de
droite il n'y a pas de place pour le
macronisme ou pour l'extrême droite
c'est ce chemin de clarté et de
positionnement que nous devons défendre
et puis enfin il faudra mes amis rebâtir
notre partie
tous ceux qui se sont prononcés
naturellement vont pas dire on va faire
la même chose
c'est assez évident donc ce que je vais
dire et peut-être une grande banalité ça
a été dit avant bien sûr qu'il faut
changer bien sûr qu'il faut donner plus
de place au militants délégués de
circonscription remettre les délégués
cantonaux faire un média des
républicains orienter nos modes de
communication sur tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui orientent l'opinion avec des
techniques modernes faire une école des
cadres Auréliennes tu l'as dit Bruno je
pense aussi même si malheureusement j'ai
pas pu t'écouter une école de formation
ouvrir le parti sur la société en faire
un lieu de vie un lieu de rencontre moi
j'ai la nostalgie de ces grands moments
de ces grandes messes portent de
Versailles où l'on écoutait Jacques
Chirac où l'on écoutait Philippe Seguin
quelle pertinence quelle vision sur
l'Europe il avait tout dit face
aujourd'hui au naufrage de cette Europe
qui nous impose des prix de
l'électricité imp cliquez sur le tarif
du gaz et qui aurait ouvre les centrales
à charbon Philippe Seguin avait tout dit
en la matière on avait ces grands
moments il faut qu'on retrouve cet
esprit de compagnonnage le bonheur
d'être ensemble malgré les débats malgré
les différences mais dire que demain on
va chasser en meute chacun avec sa force
chacun avec sa personnalité chacun avec
sa sensibilité ouvrir notre maison sur
l'extérieur et faire en sorte que à
l'intérieur rien ne soit plus forte nos
convictions et nos valeurs tout ça mes
amis il faut le faire le projet la
stratégie d'alliance surtout de
non-alliance la réorganisation de notre
maison peut-être sans changer ce siège
que personnellement je le dis je n'aime
pas beaucoup et qui nous a toujours été
associé à des défaites je le dis mais ça
c'est un sentiment très personnel
ensuite une fois étant tout cela étant
dit et je repose le diagnostic il nous
manquera toujours quelque chose
d'essentiel on peut avoir le meilleur
projet au monde en France en tout cas ça
serait déjà suffisant les idées les plus
fortes les plus pertinentes les plus
intelligentes les talents les plus
brillants dans notre famille politique
et nous n'en manquons pas et vous en
êtes on peut avoir la meilleure
organisation elle est à améliorée mais
on peut y parvenir mais il nous manquera
toujours quelque chose il nous manquera
un chef qui parle au journal de 20h pour
les républicains face à Monsieur Macron
face à Monsieur Mélenchon avec ses
délires et son danger qui parle face à
Madame Le Pen il y a des grands leaders
des monuments on en pense qu'on en veut
mais ils incarnent leur camp et bien
nous qui incarne notre camp
je reviens à la première étape du chemin
que je vous propose de suivre de cette
route droite
cette étape elle nous regarde
2027 alors je le dis et c'est là sans
doute la différence peut-être qui nous
sépare avec mes amis Bruno et Aurélien
moi je veux vous dire les choses
clairement sur le diagnostic les
primaires et j'y ai participé et tous
ceux qui ont participé ont échoué et
nous devons tous en tirer les
conséquences
les primaires nous ont conduits par deux
fois l'échec elles nous ont conduit à
l'échec parce que depuis 2012 et la
défaite de justesse de Nicolas Sarkozy
nous n'avons plus trouvé de leader donc
on a imaginé des modes de sélection il y
a eu la guerre Fillon Copé nous en
étions chacun les acteurs dans des camps
différents
il y a eu ensuite le Yalta de cette
guerre la décision de faire des
primaires en 2017
nous avons vu malheureusement ce qui est
arrivé
et nous avons choisi notre candidat très
tard et malheureusement ça ne l'a pas
protégé nous avons vu en 2021 j'ai été
j'ai tenté de porter une voix de droite
dans ce congrès nous en avons vu
malheureusement le résultat
cette procédure nous devons en tirer les
conséquences elle n'est pas opportune
elle n'est pas pertinente elle n'est pas
efficace donc nous devons la changer je
ne serai pas le président qui perpétuera
le principe des primaires je ne veux
plus qui est de primaire dans notre
famille politique
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes d'accord avec Aurélien sans
doute pas avec Bruno sur cette question
sur la méthodologie à suivre c'est à
dire qu'il faut prendre nos
responsabilités il y a un bureau
politique il y a un président qui doit
trancher qui doit faire des propositions
et au final ce sont les militants qui
doivent décider si le choix qui est fait
par le Bureau politique et le bon ou ne
pas le bon ça sera toujours vous dans
mon esprit dans ce choix site si
important si décisif mais comme dans
tous les autres qui décideraient
tout ça il faut le faire mais moi je
veux aller plus loin
et le calendrier c'est notre candidat
qui le fixera
et moi je vous dis les choses comme je
les pense parce que je crois que le
moment est venu la crise que nous
traversons la gravité du moment nous
impose de sortir de l'ambiguïté
certaines disaient qu'on ne sort de
l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment bien non
moi je crois qu'au contraire l'ambiguïté
elle nourrit la confusion notre partie a
besoin de clarté dans ses repères que je
veux apposer sur cette route il y a les
mots fidélité il y a les mots clarté il
y a les mots vérités
Clémenceau disait on ne mange jamais
autant qu'avant une élection que pendant
la guerre et qu'après la chasse bon je
crois qu'aujourd'hui le moment est venu
de dire toute la vérité
et moi je vous dis après c'est vous qui
déciderez mais je vous dis parce que
comment aujourd'hui
entretenir une forme de flou
comme dirait Martine Aubry qui met pas
ma référence habituelle quand c'est flou
c'est qu'il y a un loup et après avoir
une autre attitude et bien moi je vous
dis que cette étape procédera les temps
passée au premier semestre 2023 dans le
cas d'un grand congrès il faudra qu'on
soit un peu plus nombreux et où on
remontre notre force moi personnellement
celui qui me paraît avoir le plus
d'atouts pour relever le défi de la
victoire c'est Laurent Wauquiez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
aucun choix que aucun choix ne peut
faire l'unanimité il y a des talents il
y a des ambitions il y a des compétences
elles sont toutes légitimes et je les
respecte et je le dis à Xavier
mais moi mon devoir en tout cas mon sens
de la confiance qui doit s'installer
entre celui qui peut être sera le
président de notre famille politique et
les militants ça doit être le discours
de la vérité de la clarté à ce jour et
bien oui je pense que c'est Laurent
parce qu'il a cet enracinement
territorial solide parce que il a
l'incarnation à la fois de cette vision
de la ruralité de la force de nos
territoires qu'il préside d'une belle et
grande région qu'il est parmi ceux qui
ont le parcours universitaire le plus
brillant de notre pays qu'il est de
droite qu'il a des convictions qu'il
assument voilà mes amis cette route que
je veux tracer
que je veux vous proposer tout
simplement pour redresser les
républicains mais bien au-delà pour
redresser la France
[Applaudissements]
merci
Eric
bien il te reste il te reste 9 minutes
Eric pour répondre aux quatre questions
suivantes Derrick du Nord
inscrite dans les statues allez vous
maintenir la primaire fermée pour
désigner le candidat les républicains
prochaine présidentielle je pense que tu
as un peu répondu un peu de temps sur
les 9 minutes Jean-Jacques Dupuis dôme
quelle solution pour faire
définitivement appliquer les OQTF
enjeu majeur savoir qui nous accueillons
et qui nous ne voulons pas accueillir
aujourd'hui dans cette perte d'identité
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure il y a il
y a les attaques de l'islamisme qui
veulent et des islamistes qui veulent
effacer ce que nous sommes il y a aussi
les conséquences d'une immigration que
nous n'avons plus la capacité d'intégrer
et qui aujourd'hui nourrit un
communautarisme fort l'autre jour en
rentrant de Bordeaux j'ai rencontré dans
le TGV
une jeune femme marocaine qui est venue
me voir et qui m'a dit sur le député je
veux vous remercier pour votre fermeté
je suis marocaine et j'ai quitté Paris
parce que je ne pouvais plus je le dis
sous le contrôle d'Amine el Bahi qui a
mené ce magnifique combat contre le
communautarisme islamiste à Roubaix de
façon extraordinairement courageuse
et cette jeune femme me dit j'ai quitté
Paris parce que je ne pouvais plus
supporter de vivre à Paris avec ceux qui
s'y passait et elle me dit vous savez
une nation qui ne sait plus qui elle est
ne sait plus où elle va et il faut que
cette France elle redevienne fidèle à ce
qu'elle a été j'ai trouvé ce témoignage
extraordinaire et dans cette dans ce
délitement de notre nation il y a ces
flux migratoires inconsidérés 2 millions
d’étrangers sont arrivés depuis
l'élection de Monsieur Macron 4 millions
depuis l'élection de Monsieur Hollande
et Macron sur les 10 dernières années et
nous n'avons plus de capacité à les
accueillir en gros la politique
migratoire de ceux qui sont au pouvoir
aujourd'hui ce sont des frontières
quasiment ouvertes on a beaucoup parlé
de l'océan viking qui est un symbole de
notre démission face au flux migratoires
j'ai dit Madame Meloni 1 monsieur Macron
0 madame Meloni a résisté monsieur
Macron a cédé mais vous savez combien
rentre de chaîne Vikings tous les jours
à la frontière italienne dans mon
département menton et bien un et demi
voilà tous les jours les policiers
interpellent à Menton 300 migrants en
situation irrégulière tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours et les
flux n'ont jamais été aussi élevés alors
nous avons des frontières ouvertes nous
avons un aspirateur social qui fait que
aujourd'hui chaque étranger qui arrive
dès le premier jour reçoit des
prestations sociales en tout cas les
allocations sociales et le minimum
vieillesse sans avoir cotisé un euro
tout au long de sa vie et enfin nous
avons un système qui n'expulse quasiment
plus personne voilà et bien oui il faut
les auqtf sont ce symbole tous les jours
des faits divers dramatiques et il
s'agit pas de les exploiter ou de les
utiliser mais il suffit de lire la
rubrique des faits divers on voit de
plus en plus et c'est pas moi et c'est
pas nous qui le disons c'est maintenant
monsieur Darmanin qui le revendique
quand il dit qu'à la moitié des actes de
délinquance sont commis par des
étrangers et quand l'ancien préfet de
police nous dit que le premier moyen
d'intégration à la France pour un
étranger aujourd'hui c'est la
délinquance c'est Didier l'Allemand qui
a écrit ça dans ce livre alors comment
faire Annie et bien d'abord il faut
s'attaquer à trois vecteurs
d'immigration
demandeur d'asile les trois quarts sont
des feux de demandeurs d'asile l'asile
doit être demandé à l'extérieur de nos
frontières jamais sur le territoire
national ceux qui sont rentrés de façon
irrégulière à nos frontières ne devrait
avoir aucun droit aucun droit pour les
irréguliers ni à l'occasion ni travail
ni école je crois que ça doit être un
principe de base
pour l'immigration familiale il faut
arrêter le regroupement familial
l'article 8
l'article 8 de la CEDH tout l'interdit
et bien convoquons enfin le président de
la République qui sera élu Laurent
Wauquiez convoquera un référendum pour
interdire le regroupement familial
et enfin l'immigration étudiante 120 000
titres de séjour avec les trois quarts
de faux étudiants là aussi il faut
diviser par deux bien sûr qu'il faut
accueillir des des étudiants mais il
faut diviser par deux ou par 3 et
comment on exécute les auqtf avec des
places dans des centres de rétention 1
on remet le délit de séjour illégal 2 on
crée des places mon amendement a permis
de tripler le nombre de places à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le budget du
ministère de l'Intérieur et dans la
loopnie et Eric Poget y a travaillé
aussi donc on place systématiquement en
tout cas les plus dangereux sont ceux
qui ont été condamnés ceux qui sont là
installés qui menacent lors d'un public
on a avec Olivier marlex défendu aussi
une cour de sûreté pour expulser les
étrangers délinquants on a soyez-en
convaincu les mesures les dispositions
juridiques tout ça est prêt il ne manque
que la volonté et que celui qui pourra
les appliquer
merci
Eric de Karine du Doubs si vous êtes élu
à la tête du mouvement garderez-vous une
position de critique systématique
la critique systématique non
naturellement et nous le démontrons je
crois Gérard au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui compte c'est l'intérêt
supérieur du pays on sera toujours dans
le sens de l'intérêt général moi je le
dis et là c'est une différence avec
Aurélien et c'est peut-être le moment de
souligner aussi ce qui nous distingue il
faut bien que vous choisissez un moment
sur la question sur la question des
retraites par exemple moi je dis si on
ne prend pas une mesure d'âge et toute
notre histoire politique a prôner cette
histoire d'âge d'Édouard Balladur de
François Fillon de Nicolas Sarkozy nous
ne pourrons pas payer les retraites
demain donc il faut avoir le courage de
dire que si les pensions de retraite
veulent et que ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
les bénéficiaires de ces pensions ne
veulent pas voir demain leur pouvoir
d'achat baisser il faudra que ceux qui
cotisent aujourd'hui dans ce système par
répartition travaille un peu plus de à 3
ans progressivement dire le contraire
c'est nous conduire demain à de sombres
des illusions qui verront soit les
pensions s'effondrer soit les
cotisations augmentées donc soit les
salaires baissés bien quand on est de
droite je crois qu'il faut assurer et
assumer ce qu'on est notre histoire je
prends cet exemple pour dire que pour
moi l'intérêt de la nation sera toujours
supérieur que nous défendons toujours
l'intérêt général sans compromission
avec nos valeurs et en évitant le
désastre le naufrage que semble
démontrer ce qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale aux côtés des amis
de Monsieur Mélenchon qui installerait
une France terrifiante que nous devons
combattre et que nous ne voulons pas moi
je veux être l'ennemi de Monsieur
Mélenchon demain parce que son accession
au pouvoir serait un drame pour la
France merci
pour une dernière question à laquelle tu
as je crois
3 minutes alors soit la dernière
question mais je crois que tu as répondu
mais je vais tout de même la poser c'est
celle de Sonia de Guadeloupe présidente
de la Fédération que nous connaissons
bien prenez vous l'engagement qu'aucune
alliance ou accord de coalition avec la
majorité présidentielle verra le jour si
vous accédez demain à la présidence du
mouvement et puis si tu le souhaites il
te reste donc deux minutes mon cher Éric
pour cette question et pour un mot de
conclusion
je crois avoir répondu à cette à cette
question et elle est essentielle elle
est essentielle et tous les soirs quand
je sillonne la France avec bonheur à la
rencontre des militants dans les moments
d'échange qui sont tellement importants
avec les militants j'ai toujours cette
question voilà la question de l'alliance
avec Macron ou la question de l'Union
des droites voilà il y a toujours un ou
deux militants et je sens qu'il y a
cette inquiétude il y a cette inquiétude
parce que ceux qui transforme
aujourd'hui et ce qui malheureusement
nous tenaille c'est
le risque de la disparition bien je le
dis si nous sommes forts
si nous suivons méthodologiquement cette
route que je veux ouvrir nous n'avons
besoin d'aucune alliance c'est notre
force qui construira notre victoire
soyons droits soyons indépendants de
tout côté restons fidèle à nous-mêmes
restons fidèle à cet esprit du gaullisme
il se suffit en soi il y a tout dans le
gaullisme il y a l'indépendance
stratégique là où notre continent est
prisonnier d'un conflit terrifiant qui
nous menace il y a l'indépendance
économique il y a l'indépendance
financière il y a l'autorité il y a la
sécurité il y a l'indépendance
énergétique et bien c'est cette
indépendance qui a fait notre force qui
a fait notre grandeur et qui a fait la
France d'aujourd'hui soyons fidèles à
cet héritage pour nourrir l'espérance
d'une France qui retrouve de la grandeur
et de la hauteur
merci
Eric
[Applaudissements]